rated M for Mature a CD Projekt RED it
has always been our goal to take you on
adventures both legendary and grounded
in reality to tell you stories where
breathtaking magic fantastic creatures
and angel prophecies are interwoven with
religious fanaticism war crimes even
racism see her is she helped it's this
very vision that we've realized in our
most ambitious project to date the open
world of The Witcher Wild Hunt welcomed
travel Frank with me you [ __ ] the
northern realms in a vast continent
filled with remote outposts quaint
villages and bustling cities of
astonishing wealth
varied landscapes we'll see you riding
into mountain valleys sailing the open
seas and exploring forgotten temples
however this land is brimming with
conflict
racial hatred often erupts into violence
and war between the mighty has driven
people from their homes but one plague
runs rabid monsters they haunt the
countryside breed in city sewers and
rule the wilderness feasting on
merchants Caravan that's where you come
in ah
the witch should have expected as much
you'll play as a Witcher a monster
slayer for hire mutated to have
superhuman abilities people might think
you're a freak but everyone can use the
help of a professional writer Chloe
vampire is it 1350 I did know then a
call we put a lot of effort into
seamlessly blending gameplay with the
surrounding environment
monster behavior and tactics change
depending on the time of day or terrain
these shifting circumstances that will
often determine if you are hunter or
prey clear an area of monsters and
you'll witness people settling in
transforming dangerous areas into
sprawling hubs where you can buy and
sell gear hundreds of armor and weapon
upgrades await you but it's the way you
fight that makes all the difference
invest in sword skills to develop
special moves level up your alchemy
skills and gather rare herbs to create
potions and bombs or Master the Arcana
of magic signs and annihilate your foes
with a twist of your fingers
she's returned Geralt but all these
years in The Witcher Wild Hunt you take
on the greatest contract of your life to
track down the child of prophecy a
living weapon that can alter the shape
of the world look I might be a killer
for hire we choose you decide what kind
of man you are gonna say who you are or
do I need it look see the trouble with
me knife
indulge your human side how about I buy
everybody around thought of zone or
choose the path of a ruthless outcast
and hearing to your own brand of justice
go away or I'll kill you and watch the
world burn whoever you are in the
northern realms you'll find what you're
looking for whether it's horse racing
getting drunk following your heart or
just satisfying your passion playing
cards brawler discovering places of
power hunting treasure for joining in
ancient rituals forge your own adventure
in the most realistic fantasy of our
times welcome to The Witcher Wild Hunt